I felt myself progressing on an
exponential level every time I would
work through any situation creatively
you know after my first CP that I wrote
a few years ago I was in a completely
different state of mind and after my
album I'm in even better place hey my
name is gallant and I'm 25 years old you
know used to be really quiet walled off
kind of kid and since then I've kind of
grown into just a more open-minded and
well-rounded individual I think that it
was just a random series of emotions
that men explicably led to me
gravitating towards music as a thing
that unlocked whatever it is that was
keeping me so wallet off and I can't
explain what it was but at a young age
music just spoke to me more than any
other art form and no matter what the
quality of what I was doing was it the
act of doing it just just helped me out
a lot
I do feel like I've been you know really
embodied that a need for constant change
and constant progression when an artist
boldly says this is who I am
despite whatever classification you want
to put onto me or whatever label you
want to assign to me that really helps
lead a movie I wish that I knew when I
was starting out that really doesn't
matter that much I think there was a
period of time when I I guess when I
went to college where I kind of got out
of sync started listening to what my
peers were saying at the time and you
know there was so much focus on the
exterior because then once you give in
to those pressures that image starts to
get distorted and you start to become a
caricature of yourself for a second I
got fooled into thinking that that was
that was true
you know I couldn't be happier with you
know the rise of a streaming platform
obviously which is something I
championed since before Spotify was it
was even in America I just think it's
really important that the listeners
decide what they want to listen to
starting with making listening the
indicator of popularity rather than you
know sales was a really big step really
honestly just expressing yourself in a
unfiltered way where there's no barrier
between what's in your in your head and
what is coming out on paper or whatever
meeting
oh man in five years I mean hopefully I
am in a room playing video games playing
some Settlers of Catan with some friends
who are in the area and but as far as
what is going on outside of that room I
honestly have no idea it could be it
could be anything it could be a dressing
room for some crazy tour it could be my
house that I live in now you know I have
no idea but as long as I don't get
separated from what keeps my feet firmly
planted on the earth then I'll be happy